the environment here in Washington has
become very bitter very angry and very
gridlocked and that has been largely the
cause of the low approval ratings of the
American people of Congress and the
things we do and don't do here for them
and it's very regrettable because the
american people then think a large
number of them that the country's on the
wrong track no i don't think it's
changed me because we maintained our
residence in Arizona we raised our kids
in Arizona my character and my ideals
and my goals were formed before I came
to the Congress the United States i
railed against and fought against
wasteful anon pork barrel spending in
the corrupting influence of it but
overall I'm very much the same person
and probably reinforced in my views and
my ideals
Oh